rosen sind roth warum sich corona noch
immer vermehrt es gibt halt ständig
einen neuen infektionsherd a
das tut echt weh dosen sind rot die
meisten denken gott wäre ein mann mir
ist das egal denn ich bete 12 pflanzen
töpfer an
auch hier bewirbt sich jemand für einen
job und zwar schreibt der hallo guten
abend ich würde gerne mitarbeiten ich
bin 180 hoch aber ich spreche es nicht
gut wenn sie interesse haben können wir
uns zu einem kurzen gespräch am
donnerstag verabreden ich fange am
samstag als obstsalat an dein deutsch
ist das blech vom blech alter hier
verschenkt jemand ein klacks regal von
ikea und ein interessent schreibt hallo
ist da die kommode nie hier ist der ahne
es wirklich vom niveau her ganz tiefen
bietet jemand bleistiftzeichnungen auf
ebay an und verlangt 30 euro pro
zeichnung los er packt sogar ein
beispielbild mit in die anzeige und das
ist dieses hier ich muss wirklich los
apropos zeichnungen hier verkauft jemand
aus betzdorf ein bild von seiner
schwester an das sieht so aus dass holt
mich auf jeden fall ab falls ein neues
auto braucht es diese ebay anzeige auf
jeden fall für euch gemacht meine lieben
freunde denn jemand verkauft seinen
scheiß astra g 2.0 16v kern schrott
explodiert ich nehme den 250 euro wenn
explodierten scheiß opel astra und der
jetzt genommen haben hätte ich dazu gern
auch noch allwetterreifen sommer hat der
vollidioten club wieder wandertag oder
hat hier schreibt eine person um kurz
nach sechs sorry hatte gestern einen
unfall ging heute und der verkäufer
antwortet ja heute wieder auch gehen mit
den rest des abends zu hause möchten sie
ja noch kommen und er antwortet ok ca 20
minuten
er schreibt daraufhin ja das passt und
nicht 20 minuten später sondern
zweieinhalb stunden später schreibt er
dann sorry hatte einen unfall
[Musik]
einfach täglich den unfall wo ich sitze
schon wieder wie so eine garnele alter
da ist er gerade wieder losgeht mit den
lockdown corona zeiten habe ich hier ein
passendes angebot für euch und zwar sind
das klopapier samen ein starter kit mit
20 sammlung das kostet 50 euro
ich würde da mal ne so hallo ich hätte
interesse an der quatsch der coach comic
alter was ist dass diese scheiß
autokorrektur ich hätte interesse an dem
sofa der gehört auch zu den vollidioten
klub der gerade wandertag hat hier
schreibt eine person hallo ich
interessiere mich für zwei schallplatten
aus ihrer liste beatles abbey road und
fleetwood mac was würden sie denn kosten
diese nachricht hat er geschrieben um 41
und person antwortet sagen da bist du
normal dass du so spät schreibt hast du
eine macke oder was ich so einfach mal
hier den den klubs beim fisch nennen
könne als nächstes verkaufte jemand
seinen alten opel zafira für 1800 euro
und klar kann man das kennzeichen
irgendwie mit photoshop senden aber
sondern ist das hier nämlich das ja da
weiß man sich auf jeden fall zu helfen
hier verkauft jemand seinen makita
akkuschrauber beziehungsweise denn er
diesen massiv schreiber der vollidioten
club ist schon ein stück weiter aber
wenn du ein bisschen läuft dann erfasste
sie gleich hier interessiert sich jemand
für einen bmx rad und er schreibt es
wegen was letzte preis kann man mit
diese treppe runter kann es auch damit
treppe hoch hoch wie gehen das mit kette
kurbel und pedalen ist nicht gefährlich
ich weiß nicht
downhill fahren und sich nicht etwas
gefährlich ixic wissen ich hole gefreut
da bisschen sprinten dann hast du da
käufer mein cousin kommt heute mit dem
motorrad und holt den kühlschrank ab
verkäufer sie können noch keinen
kühlschrank mit einem motorrad abholen
käufer ein cousin ist um der macht das
motorrad ist dauert es zwei drei minuten
die sind da gerade um die ecke rum das
hier ist der nächste ebay feld und zwar
sieht es schon dass hier eine person
eine versace tasche verkauft
damenhandtasche aus wer chucky
hallo wie soll das set kosten die 30
euro könne nicht stimmen da es allein
auf amazon schon günstiger zu bekommen
ist ich habe insgesamt 25 nachrichten
auf meine anzeigen bekommen
24 davon haben ein gegenangebot
abgegeben nur du voll trotte schreibst
du einen geistigen müller denn du sollst
der welt an gefallen tun möchte dann
bekomme niemals gehen dort tragen eine
dummheit weiter spart die eine antwort
ist natürlich immer blockiert
ich sollte auf diesen taktisch zu
schlagen
eigentlich könnte ich auch direkt haben
wir verkauft eine frau ps
beziehungsweise high heels in weiß und
ein mann meldet sich daraufhin und
schreibt ihr hey würden sie mich als
putzmann nehmen ich bin auch
handwerklich sehr begabt bin gelernter
elektriker und gelernter
bauwerksabdichtung würde ich gerne ihre
stiefel schuhe und so weiter putzen
alles gratis mit freundlichen grüßen
vielen dank aber ich versuche diese
schuhe zu verkaufen ich würde geld dafür
zahlen würde ihre schuhe draußen sauber
machen egal wo sie möchten für 50 euro
das bin ich sie können sie gerne für 50
euro kaufen ist sie können die schuhe
behalten
aber ich mache die für 50 euro sauber
oder egal welche schuhe
mir geht's um dem gefühl ihren knecht zu
sein auf die knie zu seinen vielen dank
aber meine schuhe sind alle sauber sie
haben anscheinend keine interesse diese
schuhe zu kaufen
sehr schade aber trotzdem danke würden
sie mir fußnägel und hornhaut verkaufen
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
und bei diesen befehl interessiert sich
eine person für einen gaming monitor
schreibt dementsprechend hallo wie alt
ist der monitor vga und dvi es heute ja
nicht mehr up to date keine ahnung wie
alt er ist
das ist schlecht ist mir zu wenig infos
ja dann hoher ein bro frage was willst
du wissen ich habe leider keine 50 euro
da ich im monitor aber gerne haben
möchte könnte ich 20 hühner und drei
kamele anbieten ja passt obwohl
lieber 20 kamele ein citroen und der
verkäufer fragt den interessenten was
bieten sie der antwortete daraufhin 400
euro
der verkäufer antwortet 600 euro und der
käufer antwortet darauf hin wie alt sind
wie ich oder das auto du wieso wollen
sie das wissen ich suche eine freundin
da hinten sind mit sicherheit mädels
dabei interessiert sich jemand für einen
die kea bett und er fragt
dementsprechend den verkäufer was letzte
preiß vier minuten später schreibt er
beantworte fragezeichen fragezeichen und
dreieinhalb stunden später schreibt er
lass dein mann mache preis frau und geld
nix gut guten morgen ja ich antworte
ihnen gerne aber preislich werde ich
ihnen nicht weiter entgegenkommen schade
schade schokolade sagst du dann die
küchenschabe und dran die milch mit
erdbeer sahne zwecke zwar hühnerkacke
muss ich mir wohl selbst ein krake muss
ich mich doch wie beim kegeln halten an
die ebay regeln ich hoffe du hattest mit
mir nicht allzu viel verdruss mache ich
dann jetzt auch schluss
ok ging schon jean spiel schon
entschieden schien schon ich würde dir
die richtung empfehlen
genauso wie ich dass mir jetzt auch
empfehlen würde und auch eigentlich